we're going to talk about spatial hash
grids we'll go over the problem we're
trying to solve
we'll talk a bit about the alternatives
why you may or may not want to go with
them
i'll tell a little story from my game
development career that's kind of
relevant to this
and then we'll code it up so let's start
by talking about the problem
it's not uncommon for games to have a
ton of units in the world
especially games like starcraft that
kind of thing those real-time strategy
games
and from a programmer's perspective you
often need to figure out what's
happening nearby
in the vicinity of a single unit often
many times
and often you'll need to repeat that
process again and again for every single
unit
for example this guy fires into an area
an explosion goes off
something happens we need to figure out
who's dead or wounded
and obviously the faster the better so
how do we solve this
well there's a whole bunch of ways the
most obvious is the naive solution which
is
let's say we have a bunch of objects in
the scene so let's say this array here
is all of the entities in the world
now you want to find the ones that are
nearby so we'll define this function get
nearby
and pass as parameters the position and
the radius you're interested in
the naive solution is to simply iterate
the list
so first we declare the results array
and then we start iterating the whole
list
and each object we compare the distance
from the object and the position
and check that it's less than the sum of
the radius of the object and the radius
we're searching
if you were to draw a picture say you've
got this object here
with this radius so we just draw a
circle around this thing
now if we have this point and we want to
see what's close to that point we
calculate
the distance to the object and compare
it to the radius plus the search radius
if the distance is greater than the sum
of the radiuses it's too far away
otherwise if it's less than the sum of
the radiuses it's close it's nearby
and so this solution sucks because it's
slow as hell
it's order n for a single call which
means if every unit on the screen needs
to go check what's nearby
the whole thing ended up being order n
squared so
this solution is out the other thing
that typically comes up is some sort of
adaptive tree structure this is your
quad trees your oak trees your kd trees
your archeries your
loose octrees your dynamic aabb trees
your whatever random technical words
tree and these solutions are great
they can really accelerate things under
the right conditions
let's say you have a big world with
clusters of objects and big
vast sparse areas of nothing these kind
of sparse data structures are great
because they allow you to efficiently
represent these large spaces
they allow you to early out when a node
has nothing allowing you to
effectively cull and discard huge
swallows of your world all at once
but there's disadvantages too starting
with the fact that they're not trivial
to implement or maintain
if you're a big company with resources
to pour into just having a single
engineer throw themselves at tweaking
out and maintaining some hardcore data
structure
obviously go for it not sure why you're
watching this channel or taking my
advice but
go for it but for the rest of us there's
some advantages to going with something
that isn't necessarily the absolute best
but is simple to build understand and
extend when needed
so for my personal story this was back a
couple years when i had just started in
the industry
i was working on a game that would go on
to become prototype
which while not being a massive
blockbuster on the scale of other giants
sold a couple million copies so that's
respectable
there's a chance someone watching this
has played it anyway so what happened
was we had this internal team called the
advanced technology team
or atg for short and the lead rendering
engineer had spent a bunch of time
implementing this fancy pants visibility
system
i don't recall exactly what it was but i
do remember that it was some sort of
adaptive aabb tree so
fancy and complicated took a long time
to get it polished production ready
all that crap whatever and initial
results seemed to be good
so it was adopted by the prototype team
at some point i was tasked with leading
optimization efforts so i fired up the
profiler and
you can kind of guess where this is
going so i load up the profiler one day
and notice that the
visibility system is taking up an
enormous amount of frame time
if i recall correctly we had about a 90
million cpu cycle per frame budget
and this thing was taking about 70 to 80
million cycles
meaning it was taking nearly the entire
frame
and remember how i said it's important
for code to be easy to maintain and
extend
well nobody really understood this data
structure there was no documentation of
any kind because
games and the original guy wrote it the
lead engineer had left the company at
this point
so this was a complete mess like the
code itself wasn't messy but it was
complicated
just sucking down cpu cycles pointers
everywhere
cached mrs galore it had it all so i
started screwing around with it and what
i found was if i took this tree
structure
and i just made everything stay in the
root node and never split
the whole thing ran considerably faster
at least on the xbox 360.
about 10 times faster to be exact i
committed the change to perforce and
reported the findings to the tech
director and team and what ended up
happening was that one of the senior
engineers on the technology team ended
up being tasked with building a new
visibility system
a simple one a glorified array basically
all sim de-optimized with some extra
handmade occluders that artists could
build into the scene
that's it that hand rolled and optimized
version ended up being fast enough that
the visibility system disappeared off
the profiler
so job done the moral of the story is
that sometimes simple solutions
implemented well are good enough i get
that working on these other data
structures is super sexy and fun
but you know we're in the business of
making games not
visibility systems okay so let's talk
spatial hash grids now
spatial hash grids are conceptually
really simple
let's start with a simple scenario so
let's say that our world is this
rectangle so i'll just draw a quick
rectangle on the screen
and let's say you've got a whole bunch
of crap scattered throughout your world
so i've got trees and rocks and people
scattered everywhere
and the problem you're trying to solve
is given say this character here
you want to be able to query and find
out who's nearby
the way that you can do that is by
dividing the world into fixed size
cells and then for any given point in
the world you basically hash it to one
or more of these spatial cells
so if i have this big tank for example
it's bigger than a single cell so i'd
insert it into all four of these cells
that it's touching
and then when you want to find out
what's nearby it's a simple matter of
checking all the cells in the area and
compiling a list of everything you see
so let's code up a simple one i'm not
going to optimize this in any way
because i want to make this super clear
how it works
i'll follow up with an optimized version
so stay tuned for that
the first thing we need to do is declare
a class we'll call it spatial hashgrid
and we'll start with just a basic
constructor with
a few parameters bounds and dimensions
i'll explain what these parameters will
mean bounds will be the
min and max of the area that the grid
will be operating on so
if your world goes from negative
thousand negative thousand to a thousand
thousand
then you're going to feed in two arrays
to bounds dimensions
is the other parameter we need to
initialize the spatial hash grid and
that controls how many cells we'll have
along each dimensional axis
so if the world is 100 units wide and we
have 5 cells
then each cell will span 20 units the
only other thing we need to do here is
initialize the cell's property
and we can do this a number of ways but
since i want to just illustrate the
basics here we'll do this the simplest
way possible
and we'll allocate a map to hold the
cells now the public way that you'd use
this spatial hash grid is kind of like
well let's say that i have this code
here so i'll create a new grid by going
const grid
equals new spatial hash grid and let's
pretend that the bounds and dimensions
is declared somewhere now in a game
setting you're going to need a few
operations
first off you'll need a way of creating
a new client for the grid
in other words normally you want to
write something like const client
equals grid dot new client and the
parameters
with parameters containing a bunch of
crap like position size
that sort of thing now once you have a
client you'll need a way of updating
that client
so it would look something like
client.position equals newposition
and then you'd want to notify the grid
of the changes with a call like
grid.updateclient
the reason being if that unit or entity
is moving around in the world you
obviously need a way of notifying the
grid that its position has changed so
the grid can do any bookkeeping
necessary
now for the most obvious usage and
that's finding nearby units and that
needs to look something like
const nearby equals grid dot find nearby
and pass it in the parameters and that
would return some sort of list or
something of the nearby clients
lastly there's one final cleanup
operation we need to do and that's when
we want to destroy the clients
at some point there's going to be a need
to remove a client from the grid so
we'll need an operation like this where
we can go grid.remove client
and pass in the client and that will
just remove the client from the grid so
that it isn't being actively maintained
anymore and won't show up in queries
so we got to implement these four
interfaces which should be enough for
most cases
starting with new client so we'll write
out the function definition here
with two parameters those being position
and dimensions
that being the initial position of the
client and the width height
of the client respectively and all this
function is going to do is create a new
client dict so i'll copy these
parameters in
so we'll copy both this position and
dimensions into the new client dict
and we'll add this indices property
which we'll get used in a bit
now new client has to actually insert
this into the grid
so let's write a call to a non-existent
function this dot
insert client and of course we'll go and
fill that in
now the insert client function i'll just
declare this below
and it just has the one parameter that
being the client
being inserted by the way this isn't
intended to be a public function
conceptually this function is super
simple using the position of the client
and the size of the client we need to
loop over the cells it potentially
touches
and insert it into those cells so you
can see that i've just used javascript
destructuring syntax to make this a bit
more readable by turning position and
dimensions into x y
wh next i need to figure out the min max
range of the cells we're iterating over
and so we need some sort of function
that does the conversion from a position
to a cell index in other words if you're
looking at the grid and i ask you what
cell index this point is in
you need to provide an index so that i
can look up that cell specifically
so we're doing just that with again some
functions that haven't been filled in
yet
but we're calling them get cell index
and the parameters to this function
are just the x y coordinates we're
interested in for this function we
actually need to calculate both the min
and the max range of the cells so what
we need to do is take the position
and subtract half the width and height
for one index and add half the width and
height for the other
and that'll give us a range we can
iterate on so now that we have these two
we'll just store them in the client just
because we'll need them later
then we need to write two for loops that
iterate from the min to the max in both
dimensions
both in x and y once you have the loops
we'll need to use the two coordinates or
cell indices to construct a key for the
cell map so we're going to again
call a function that doesn't exist in
this case it's this dot key and we'll
pass
in the coordinates and it'll pass back a
string that we can use to look up in the
cell map
now we just need to add a quick check to
make sure the cell map has been
initialized
since we didn't do that right in the
constructor lazy initialization isn't a
good way to do this and
i do not like doing this in real
production code but this is a tutorial
so if it's not constructed we allocate a
new set
lastly now that you have the key and you
know what cell is initialized
so you insert it and we're done except
for the fact that we have two
unimplemented functions so let's go
implement them
starting with the key function this is
going to be relatively simple
there's two parameters which just
represents the x y indices of the cell
we're interested in
and the goal here is just to generate a
hashable key that can be used in the
cell map to uniquely identify this cell
and that's as easy as just concatenating
these two indices together as a string
with a period in between
that's it should work fine so let's move
on
the other function that we needed was
the get cell index function
which given the position of coordinates
will compute the x y
index of the cell this position belongs
to
and although this looks pretty involved
it's not really that involved
the first calculation here where we
calculate the x value
all this is doing is taking the position
subtracting the minimum bound
and then dividing by the max minus the
min or the total bounds of the area
what that gives you is a value between 0
and 1 and then i just clamp it to the
range 0
1 just in case the position was outside
that range after that
it's a simple matter of taking that 0 to
1 value multiplying by the number of
cells minus one
and then turning that into an integer
and of course we do it for both the x
and the y value giving us a tuple of x
y indices for the cells so we're all set
for new client
now we should move on to the most
obvious usage which is to find nearby
things
so we start by declaring the function
and takes two parameters
position and dimensions and these are
pretty self-explanatory
position is the location you want to
query for nearby clients and dimensions
is the width height around that point to
search i.e
how big of an area do you want to search
now keep in mind
grid search isn't perfect it may return
things slightly further away but that's
normally a non-issue so this function
fundamentally what it needs to do is
figure out the cell coordinates for the
bounds of the query
so the position plus and minus the
bounds after that it'll need to loop
between the min and max
indices and basically just collect every
client from every cell
concatenating them all into one big list
so that's what we're doing
i did some quick destructuring at the
start of the function just to make
things a bit easier to read
and then these two calls to get cell
index get the min
and max indices for the cells after that
it's a simple matter of iterating along
the range of cells in both the x and y
axis
pretty much exactly the same thing as we
did in the insert function
the major difference here being we need
to do a small check here
so once we have the cell key we need to
check that there's actually a cell
with that key because there may never
have been a unit inserted into it and so
it doesn't exist
remember these are lazily created after
that i declare this client
set because the clients may show up more
than once
for example if you have a big unit that
spans multiple cells
it gets inserted into multiple cells but
here in the find nearby function
we only want to record seeing it once so
we can use a set
to trivially make sure that the list of
clients is unique
so if the cell exists we just iterate it
take every element from that set and
insert it into the result set after that
you return it job done that's pretty
much everything
find nearby needs to do let's move on to
update
so we'll declare this update client
function and it has one parameter
the client that's being updated and you
can implement
update trivially as just two operations
removing the object from the grid
and then inserting it back into the grid
that essentially accomplishes what an
update function needs to do
so here we called this delete client
followed by this call to insert
and that's it although delete client
doesn't exist yet but it's literally the
next thing we're going to implement
so we're already done here okay last
function
the delete client function and this is
conceptually
super simple what you're going to do is
given the client
you get the indices that were stored
earlier in the client dict
then we just iterate the range of cells
that this client was inserted to
and called delete so that's it each cell
contains a set which has a delete
function so you don't need to go
searching for the item yourself
set takes care of it reasonably fast too
the ecma standard doesn't specify the
exact data structure a set needs to have
only that it provides sub-linear access
times
and that should be it we're all done
i've put together a little test bed
where we can see the whole thing in
action
if we load it up you can see red spheres
moving around i've put a few hundred
spheres into a loosely bounded area and
they're just kind of wandering around
randomly
i've given them some basic flocking
behaviors check out that video if you
want to understand more
but anyway they're just wandering around
and we're doing a query for all nearby
units for the red sphere
and any nearby units we're coloring
green now notice that it's not
absolutely perfect because of the way
the grid works
you're guaranteed to get everything
that's at least the distance you specify
but you may also get a few that are
slightly further away depending on where
you
are relative to the cell we can also run
some numbers
so i cropped out a quick naive version
of the spatial grid using a linear
algorithm
it just straight up searches every
client and now we can compare numbers on
performance
the basic setup i have is i have a
hundred thousand clients in a dense area
and we're going to do a test using a
thousand random queries on both
the naive version and the spatial grid
we just built
so as a baseline doing a thousand
queries takes about
six and a half seconds a little bit more
than that on the naive version
and that shouldn't be a surprise
considering it has to iterate every
single client doing bounding volume
tests
that means a thousand queries times a
hundred thousand clients
or a hundred million operations let's
compare that to the basic spatial hash
grid we built
and in this case we're getting way way
better numbers
a thousand queries only takes about 18
milliseconds
roughly that's an absolutely fantastic
improvement
but it does come at a slight cost
because just raw queries isn't the only
thing you need to do
units need to move around so we can also
compare forcing all the clients to move
and see how long that takes
and in this case the naive version is
obviously better since it didn't have to
do anything
all we're recording here is roughly the
overhead of the loop and function calls
and
probably the timer but the spatial hash
grid doesn't do
too bad takes around 350 milliseconds or
so to get it done
as a bonus treat here's a much improved
version there was some easy low hanging
fruit in here performance
wise so i went ahead and made a faster
version here are the numbers from the
improved one
query times improved significantly
taking less than half the time as before
same with the updates both happen
significantly faster in the newer
version
in the next tutorial we'll step through
with the profiler and i'll show you step
by step how i looked at the performance
here
what i looked for and how i improved on
this anyway
this was just me trying out a new format
for these tutorials
hope you enjoyed it and learned
something new in the process
code should all be up on github if i
remember to upload it
let me know what you thought in the
comments below also like and subscribe
as always
until next time cheers